[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed or a bear that you beside me
without it
[Music]
hey y'all some exciting news before we
dive into this episode the minimalists
are going to host a private podcast and
live stream exclusively for our patreon
supporters we're calling this ask the
minimalists anything anyone who
contributes two dollars or more over at
our patreon page can attend this special
live stream if you can't make the
livestream itself the live session the
live podcast don't worry you'll still
have access to the private video and the
private audio podcast efforts recorded
we hope to do this at least once a
quarter maybe more frequently for our
patreon supporters and please note that
none of the money from our patreon
campaign goes to our personal bank
accounts rather what we're going to do
is use these funds to build our own new
podcast studio and a film studio which
is going to allow us to do a bunch of
really cool things like take live colors
on the air improve overall audio quality
and bring guests on the show we're also
going to hire a full time filmmaker to
create a video version of this podcast
and we also want to produce a bunch of
other meaningful video creations like
webseries TV shows interviews
documentaries video essays and more and
because we refuse to clutter our
podcasts with advertisements patreon
really is the best way for us to fund
these creative endeavors together so let
me ask you this are you willing to help
if so please become a patron today head
on over to patreon comm slash the
minimalists or you can go to our website
it's just the minimalists comm and click
on the donate button at the top we'll
put a link to that in the show notes as
well and please know that your support
is greatly appreciated together we will
create something meaningful
live from the House of Blues in
Cleveland Ohio my name is Joshua fields
Milburn and I am Ryan Nicodemus hello
Cleveland welcome to the middlemost
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less we
have a microphone right here and we
welcome your questions
you know what oh they're actually
running up to it this time this is great
this is actually the best time to ask
question because we do like a hug line
afterward but we can't ask answer five
or six hundred questions in a row
tonight
so this is the best time to come up and
ask your questions now we've been on the
road for a few months now this is we
halfway this mark the halfway point we
get a two-month break after this which
is really nice but it has been
outstanding this is the end of the first
leg and what a great place to end it
here in Ohio you know Josh makes that
joke about like that's what you do when
you live in Ohio as you move but we
freaking love Ohio yeah so anyone from
Young Youngstown here tonight I thought
about Akron anyone from Canton nice
welcome welcome to all of you yeah we're
we're Gryphon house yeah he's one of my
favorite musicians he's he'll be playing
with us in Nashville later this year yes
yeah so we have been all over Ohio
we're from Dayton Ohio originally and we
had three tour stops to Cincinnati
Columbus and now we're ending it here in
Cleveland for those of you listening at
home if you want to see us on tour we
still have 21 more stops this year we're
headed to Canada we're headed to a bunch
of other places all throughout the
United States down south east coast west
coast mountains and everywhere in
between find the cities at les is now
calm how do you with your question and
what's your name actually
I'm from Geneva about an hour east from
Cleveland you might turn that mic down
just a little bit there you go better
yeah Paige hi yeah um so my question is
I I'm a minimalist in training I guess
um and I'm into the love languages so
meeting people and working with people
knowing that they like words of
affirmation or gift-giving or physical
touch things like that so um as a
minimalist in training when I see
someone or meet someone who enjoys
receiving gifts physical gifts
what's your opinion on that feeding
their love language with that but not
enabling like the stuff I think it's a
fair question I think we get confused
when we think of gift-giving we often
think of me the most parodic
exaggeration or example of it is like
the car commercial with the bow on the
car look I love you I just went into
$60,000 worth of debt to prove it and so
that's sort of like one type of
gift-giving I suppose I think that's a
type of gift that giving is a Romance
language the same way that pig latin is
a Romance language like kind of thing
right or that kind of gift-giving as a
love language like Pig Latin is a
Romance language I should say because
when I look at at what people mean by
gift-giving it doesn't have to be
gifting an obligatory physical item what
we mean by gift-giving is contribution
what we mean by gift-giving it think
about why you actually give a gift to
someone there's two reasons usually one
is oh [ __ ] I'm obligated to do this it's
your birthday it's Valentine's Day
it's Christmas it's sweetest day it's
Flag Day is right around the corner
and and and so we what we do is we like
feel obligated like oh crap
tomorrow's Christmas and there's like
seven stores open now and I better hurry
up and find something before they all
closed because that sense of obligation
and that is that means we've really been
enculturated and becomes as cultural
imperative to say here I gave you this
shiny widget and what shiny widget did
you give me so I can compare my love to
your love that's not why you really want
to give gifts the other reason you want
to give gifts is far more noble and far
more important it's because you want to
add value to someone else's life I don't
think we can commodify love and so you
don't want to give a gift to show
someone you love them you give a gift
because you care about someone and you
want to add value to their life in some
way you think it's going to augment
their experience of life and so that
word experience is key I go out of my
way when I am giving gifts to do three
things one is I try to gift experiences
whenever possible and sometimes that
means gifting it through a physical
medium I give you example I have a four
year old now i neva NIF I'm going to
gift here's an example Bex my partner
and her rnl are out there paddled with
Santa paddleboarding today and instead
of just like taking her there she'll
like go get the rent in the stands
stand-up paddleboard and present it to
her as a gift even though she's really
gifting the experience and renting this
the stand-up paddleboard and that's one
way to show hey we're having an
experience together here's the physical
object that represents that as opposed
to just buying a thing the second thing
I'll try to do is give consumables
whenever possible so a really great bag
of coffee or your bottle of wine meal
and experience some sort of shared
shared consumable that we can have
together and the third thing I try to do
is I avoid those obligatory gift-giving
holidays now I get that some of you you
feel so obligated you're going to go out
and and you know for the birthday and
for Christmas whatever I think that's
fine but today is what June 25th
and it'd be much easier to go up to
someone and say here I got this thief
concert tickets for you Ryan and he's
going to think like wait it is June 25th
what the hell is today why did you get
these for me well because I thought
they'd add value to your life and
because I care about you I want to add
value to your life in some way so I
really hope you enjoy it and I think if
I do that that it's much more meaningful
because he didn't have an expectation
for a gift to that day and so when those
expectations are gone it feels a lot
more meaningful yeah Maya I think my mom
I don't think she would say like
gift-giving is one of her love languages
but she absolutely loves gifts and you
know I don't I I I totally agree like
give gifts when they're not on holidays
but I'm not opposed to giving gifts on
holidays like especially Mother's Day
like my mom if if I didn't send her some
flowers and chocolates on Mother's Day
like she would have her feelings hurt
and I'm not going to hurt her feelings
because I'm you know I don't want to
give a gift on a holiday so if it means
a lot to that person like I will
absolutely go out of my way to give that
person a gift and you don't make it does
make I'm sorry glad you don't think it's
an unreasonable expectation like if you
expected flowers and chocolate from you
three times a week you'd be like and she
was like and if you don't give me
flowers and chocolate three times a week
my feelings are going to be here you say
well that's an unreasonable expectation
right sure and it doesn't have to be
flowers or chocolates it could be a
phone call it could be a gift of me just
spending time with her and or bringing
her out to Montana or something like
that
um but I guess what I'm trying to say is
that yes I don't love to go out and buy
physical items but if there is something
that someone needs like my little sister
you know a few years ago she was it was
summerses yearning to start school she's
like man I really need some jeans and it
was it was a birthday and I but just
happened to be your birthday I'm like
it's your birthday today I let's go get
you some jeans great and she really
really appreciated that I think that if
someone's love language is gift-giving
which I would agree with Josh like it's
because if you bought someone a tie clip
and they didn't wear ties like that's
not really lovely that's silly
but but yeah it definitely challenges
you a little bit more to be deliberate
with the gifts especially when you're
aspiring minimalist which by the way
don't tell anybody but I'm still kind of
trying to be a minimalist I mean at the
end of it there is no there is no end
end to it um I still have a junk drawer
I don't have you know two junk drawers
or three junk drawers when that junk
when that first drunk drunk George Oh
what was Freud say when that first junk
drawer starts to overflow like I don't
come up with junk drawer number two like
I will go through that stuff and clear
now um but back to the gift-giving thing
yeah I mean it's it's something that
people really really some people really
really enjoy is getting a gift before I
left Cincinnati I got my mom a few gift
certificates too for massagers
non-obligatory day surprised there with
them she was totally ecstatic so yeah I
would say yes as a minimalist it's
definitely a little bit more maybe a
little bit more challenging to show that
person that not that you love them with
the gift but that you respect them and
you respect what they want and what they
and what they what they find valuable I
guess but it doesn't mean that you have
to just you know cut it off and say I'm
sorry I'm a minimalist I don't buy stuff
for people I mean that's not how it
works
hobbie hi what's your name
I'm Lia I want us everything thank you
you guys have added a lot of value to my
life I'm 20 years old and I discovered
y'all in March are you from
okay Tampa Florida Portland Maine and
wait wha
Mooresville North Carolina welcome but
currently forlán yes thank you um I am
here visiting my good friend Audrey and
Ohio so anyway um so anyway I yes thank
you my question is
oh also I'm so I'm so dedicated to
minimalism I decided to cut my hair
shorter than I thought I was going to
tie that note um so anyway my question
is as a 20 year old I feel like you guys
give a lot of advice on like how to like
kind of break it to yourself so your
minimalist but like I don't have a self
yet I don't want one right now but if
I'm like looking for a partner and I
want to like let someone know that I'm a
minimalist or that I really like that
work it's kind of aggressive but like
that I want to live a meaningful life
you know what I mean with less and how
do I go about you know what word do you
like look like it's kind of like being a
vegan like if you're vegan you what you
you want to say I'm a vegan you say like
I eat plant-based diet right yeah
hopefully I like because I am vegan but
I'm not a vegan I don't say that so I
was like I guess you could say I'm on a
consumption diet yeah so here so I mean
there I'll give you a few words but I'll
say you don't even need a label if you
feel like you need one that's fine
I Ryan and I are the minimalists because
the domain was $7.99
and if you need a different word to me
minimalism was a great word because it
was so sort of subversive and
in-your-face at first and it it conjured
these images of sort of stark white
walls and and and aggressively simple
and I think I've kind of needed that
personally like I needed to be shook a
little bit and say what the hell are you
doing with your life but I also realized
that's not appropriate for everyone so I
think there are some other words from
softer words you could say simplicity
you can say intentional ism you can say
deliberate ISM you could say
essentialism I heard someone say
thoughtful over here that's a good one -
yeah yeah I thought thoughtful is is
thoughtful and and what I'll say is
you're at a good place right now because
you're asking the question not when
you're you know many years into
relationship like I was realizing that
my values didn't align with my partners
and I actually had when I was married my
spouse we she was a great person we even
had similar interests to each other
which really clouded things because we
didn't have the same values I think it's
important and so eventually when it
comes time for you to look for a partner
or just to date someone in general I
think it's important to figure out what
their values are but first you have to
be really clear on what your values are
okay and and Ryan and I also talked
about the four different types of values
I'll run through them really quickly for
those of you we also did a whole podcast
episode called values you can go back
and listen to but the foundational
values are I think pretty much the same
for everyone and you can add or subtract
but there's five of them we wrote about
in our first book minimalism live a
meaningful life health relationships
passion or what you could call
creativity growth and contribution those
are the the foundation of a living a
meaningful life and I think if any if
we're ever feel and discontented it's
because we don't feel like we're
fulfilling all five of those values on
top of that you sort of your core values
to continue the metaphor of the
foundation this would sort of be the
structure of the house the this will
holds your house up and you probably
have ten or twenty a dozen or two dozen
core values and they can be things like
free speech and autonomy
and freedom and discipline and sexuality
and you get to pick what those values
are and those tend to be different for
everyone but you'll find when you find a
partner that they tend to overlap quite
a bit and also you'll learn from their
values as well sitting down and doing
this exercise Beck's and I kind of look
at our values together once a month and
once a year we really try to reassess
and say is it still a value and how do i
define these and these core values you
want to be able to find it within a
sentence you should be your value should
be tweetable and in that way you know
exactly what they're I've got about
20-25 values I've written down and back
says something similar on top of that
you have your minor values things like
aesthetics or for me it's coffee it's a
minor value it's not a core value like
can I do without is that absolutely
necessary of course not absolutely
necessity but it certainly adds value to
my life and in some way and in this
fourth level we have these imaginary
values and this is where we get caught
up we often spend much of our time doing
things that we pretend that value to our
lives when they don't actually we have
to be careful with those to eliminate as
many of those imaginary values as
possible so they don't get in the way of
what's truly important and I think once
you understand what your values are
you'll be able to start discussing that
with other people figuring out if your
values match with theirs yeah I mean at
the end of the day um yeah don't act
like if you're on the first date you
don't ask them like hey are you a
minimalist by chance it's probably the
wrong opening line um and you know when
I first met my partner Mariah I didn't
you know say you know hi I'm Ryan I'm
I'm a minimalist well you know first off
I don't want to be like here check out
my website
[Laughter]
but you know the other thing too is like
I don't really require I didn't require
someone to be minimalist and she wasn't
but we had like Josh said you know very
similar values like that is what I
focused on and when I first was at her
house and likes all the 80 pairs of
shoes that she had and like the wall to
wall closet worth of clothes that she
had I didn't judge her for it but what I
did think was okay if this goes any
further and we move into each other like
this is going to come with her and I've
got to be prepared for that like is this
something that I still want to pursue
and at the end of the day like yeah
absolutely like we we got along so well
and I loved her I respected her and you
know I think when you get into a
relationship where you truly do love and
respect someone you can get to a point
where you appreciate the differences and
when you appreciate someone's
differences like you're going to support
them even though maybe it's not exactly
what you know you would want now if I
walk into her house and leg
I don't like she was a Satan worship or
something like that would have been like
yeah that doesn't really align with my
my values and beliefs um you know this
is going to work I mean there are some
things that that will totally you know
step on those that you do have to say no
to I don't know why I thought of that
but you prosthetic into my head but uh
but but yeah I mean if if you meet
someone it's not about even putting a
label on what you're trying to do as
much as do you like if that person is
start there if you like who they are
then great go on a second date with them
learn a little bit more about them and
as you get to know someone these things
will start to come out and then you can
come and decide for yourself if it's
something you want to pursue and in the
again like on the first date you're not
going to be like oh nice to meet you
I've brought my list of 46 things that
are my values um can you write your list
of what your values are for me I mean
you're not going to figure it out in one
day but yeah it's not really for me it's
not important
someone is a minimalist as much as it is
they love and respect me and support me
and what I want to do and it's funny is
like over the last you know four or five
years mariah has totally gotten rid of a
lot of her shoes and clothes and stuff I
never asked her to get rid of anything
um in fact now I think if I asked her
like do you think you're a minimalist
you probably would say yes but I don't
know like when she like turned that
corner
um because for the longest time she
would she would say oh yeah you know now
the mental mores but after six years of
living with me and seeing the benefits
not me hounding her not me pressuring
her she has finally you know kind of
accidentally become a minimalist
accident of minimalist calm someone
would go and buy that domain right now
but yeah that's that's what that's
what's more important for me it's does
this person love me do they respect me
do they support me do they appreciate
Who I am and that's that's what's for me
is what is important about a
relationship not just a romantic
relationship either even my friends well
thank you and I wanted to thank you for
making me not only as well making me a
minimalist vegan not only a vegan
now the minimalist again it's just like
the icing on the cake honestly thank you
thank you
one of the things just added that really
quick your commonality so shared
interests beliefs and even values they
add connection to a relationship a
friendship intimate relationship
whatever differences especially
different beliefs that they can add
passion to relationship it's good that
everyone everything isn't the same and
the problem with either one is if it's
all passion and no not built on values
then you know it's a castle made of sand
and if it's all connection but no
passion you get bored pretty quickly
howdy what's your name hi I'm Margo hey
Margo you as well where you from I'm
originally from Michigan but I just
moved to Cleveland in September and it's
treating me pretty well welcome this is
a pretty great city
yeah so um Mike well I have two
questions someone got away with that in
a previous podcast so I long from when
you start to consider minimalism - when
you get to the point of discovering your
passions and all the other things how do
you it by how do you advise folks to
manage the fear that comes with all of
that what are you afraid of letting go
of things why cause of the attachment
associated with them why you have an
attachment counselling session all of a
sudden you didn't know that's it Mike
hahaha here's what here's well tell you
and I'll let you off the hook now but
these are some questions you you
seriously want to dive into that but the
talk I was given earlier some of the
questions that I asked there was like
when did I give so much meaning to all
this stuff what is truly important in my
life
why have I been so discontented who is
the person I want to become and how will
I define my own success and those were
tough questions and I think minimalism
when I look at minimalism it's less of
an answer and more of a series of
questions that provide more questions
actually and to me that's a good thing
because it's exploration minimalism is
not the destination it's not even the
path it's the tool we use to clear the
path to get where we're going and so for
me I has asked our ask questions about
thanks
it's it was the tool that they got that
got the excess out of the way Ryan and I
were doing a Facebook live session
recently and some troll pops on there
and said you guys are minimalist you
didn't get rid of anything important to
which I responded you're right I didn't
[Applause]
and and so when I think about fear we've
written a few things on our website
there's an essay very early on called
how to make a damn decision and it's
still one of the more popular things on
there I would encourage you to check
that out but when I think about fear I
think of two questions that come up
what's the worst thing that can happen
because we all hear this right like
what's the worst thing that can happen
well sometimes some really terrible [ __ ]
can happen right what if I bungee jump
without a bungee cord what's the worst
that can happen
well you'll die but I ask that question
because most of the time when I answer
that question aloud it makes me realize
how silly my fear is right what is the
worst that can happen but then I like to
flip it around and I ask myself what's
the best that could happen and I realize
that usually drastically outweighs the
worst that can happen good
I wish the second question my second
question is you to speak of trying
something even if it means failure so
how do you manage difficult like
negative feedback that you sometimes get
like self-pity self-doubt that can come
with failure oh man I've gotten really
good at failing
and that's what I would suggest you do
like failure ass off like you know don't
go ahead and take out a million dollar
loan and go and like knowing that you're
going to declare bankruptcy but don't
let the fear of failure stop you from
doing anything you know at the end of
the day when we Thanks
when we first started the minimalists
man anytime like anyone gave us any
negative feedback or like an article was
written about us that was negative I
mean how would like just give me anxiety
the whole day if you know if it was a
comment on Facebook I would like you
know craft out a response and and you
know now like I'm so used to the critics
that I just don't care anymore like at
the end of the day like it doesn't
matter what other people think about me
and matters what I think about me
and like that is what enables me to fail
as much as possible because at the end
of the day um if Josh and I try some
like perfect example last night we're in
Columbus and Jessica Williams our
wonderful social media lady who's
sitting right there we cannot we the
reason why our social media looks so
great is because of her so thank you so
much Jessica Williams for doing
everything that you do and she always
has like gratuity she's got a really
good eye for stuff really good ideas and
she was like hey why don't you guys try
a selfie at the end of at the end of
your show and like you know we'll post
it and it'll be fun like you'll get the
crowd involved and my first thought was
like I don't know if she's kind of
cheesy like doing a selfie but I'm like
you know what Jess knows way better than
I do I was like let's do it
so like she came onstage
brought us the phone like we take we try
to take this selfie now imagine trying
to take a selfie with all these lights
shining on the camera and it just didn't
work and it was kind of like the crowd
that kind of walled a little bit and it
was it failed it's essentially hate and
you know at the end of the day that's
okay like we tried it I feel good about
it I learned something from it like
that's what I've learned a really love
failure because I learned things from it
there is a awesome TED talk out there um
I forget do you remember the gentleman's
name who went out and practiced like a
hundred days of failure I don't know his
name but I know the TED talk you're
talking abut in the show notes for this
um for this podcast but this this guy
essentially saved up enough money to
quit his job and he went to his wife
he's like hey we've got enough money to
pay those for a while I'm going to quit
my job I want to take six months I
really want to start this new business
and see where it goes and she was like
great so I was like good plan so he quit
his job for like the first month you
know he had his business plan got like a
you know some kind of capital investor
angel investor like involved with it was
really excited about it they're working
through at the end of month three like
the rug just got swept out from
underneath of them and he was like huh
what sucks I guess I'm gonna go back to
work so he went to his wife he's like
hey yeah this failed so I'm gonna go
back to work and she was like what wait
a minute she's like he said six months
it's only been three months like why
don't you take the additional three
months and and see if you can maybe do
something else he's like yeah you're
right I probably should
so he'd break more business plans reach
out to people but you know he would
always get to this point where he
couldn't really get past that like
reaching out to folks he wasn't nearly
as ambitious as what he was when he
first you know attempted and he started
thinking about it he's like you know
like I'm really scared of failing again
and then he like kind of thought to
himself like this is really silly like
why would I be skin
aired a failing like it's it's I mean it
was like just this paralyzing fear he
had so he decided to do these 100 days
of failure worth every single like he
would he went to you know some local
hamburger joint and after he ate his
hamburger like he'd go through the cash
share and he's like hey can I have a
refill on this hamburger or he literally
like waved down a trooper like a cop in
his car hiccups like what's wrong with
mine he's like oh nothing man he's like
I've just never driven a cop car before
can't drive your car like just really
going out of his way intentionally
trying to fail and I don't want to like
spoil the whole talk but it's really
encouraging talk but what that talk
encouraged me to do which we saw we
actually saw him give the talk at the
WDS in Portland Maine that urban sorry
Portland Oregon that Chris Keller go put
puts on every year I think it was like
2013 is when we went but regardless like
seeing that talk in 2013 it totally like
gave me the courage to like not be
scared of what other people were going
to say and you know when I when I let
myself down I take that as an indicator
that I need to learn something I don't
really man like the self if I really do
I really really screw up which I do
don't get me wrong and I do have that
self pity it is still like a oh [ __ ]
dude like don't do that again like don't
ever get you know so don't let the fear
of failure stop you from trying things
no one no one is going to no one that
matters is going to judge you at the end
of the day like anyone who takes you
while you're down like they're not your
friend anyway and there's no reason for
you to even hang out with those people
so
you're true friends people that love you
your family if they love you want you to
be happy like they're going to support
you whether you succeed or fail thank
you
and real quick before we move on to the
next question here for the folks
listening to this at home if you have a
comment or a tip for anyone who's asked
a question or anyone who's getting ready
to ask a question you can give us a call
for zero six two one nine seven eight
three nine or you can send a voicemail
right from your phone podcast at the
minimalists comm where our favorite
comments and tips at the end of this
episode as well as the end of future
episodes Ryan do you know what time it
is oh yeah it is time for our hashtag
ask the minimalist lightning round where
where usually we answer questions to
social media but it'd be really strange
if like we were just on our phones up
here answering questions in social media
so we will turn these next few questions
into yes short well you could your
question because only if you want I
guess it but we're going to try to give
you a pithy tweetable answers usually
Josh and I have about a week to prepare
these answers and now we've got about
five seconds so we might ramble a little
bit but we'll probably get to a point
where we wrap it up into a nice
tweetable bite-sized answer so yeah you
can find this at the minimalists on all
the Twitter's and Facebook's and
instagrams and stuff so yeah also just
live tweets this so we use the hashtag
less is now which is name of the tour
and so if you want to check that also
you post any pictures and I use that
hashtag and we'll reshare some of our
favorites how they what's your name uh
my name is Mary Mary where you from
beverage Louisiana welcome yes hell of a
drive yeah where my husband and I were
on a road trip oh also happy accident
that our past did you drag him here
hopefully you didn't hate it sir
yeah well first of all I've been messin
I'm glad I listened to your podcast as
regular can't talk regularly because I
am been mesmerised by your fluorescent
shoelaces the entire time but this is
it's good that this is going to be a
simple answer because I don't really
have anything to you for meaningful to
add I just wanted to ask you we're doing
a like wholly minimalist pilgrimage
through Dayton on our way back home what
is there to do in Dayton other than get
gas so I'll tell you this we've been to
49 states and countless cities at this
point over the last six or seven years
since we've been doing this and Dayton
Ohio is still one of my favorite cities
in the world I mean if there's there's
some like touristy stuff that actually I
had to go away from Dayton and we moved
from Dayton like five years ago I just
had graduated from from the city after
31 years and when I came it was until I
came back that like I started
appreciating a lot of the places I
couldn't appreciate from when it was it
close so I mean you have the air force
museum if you really want to see how
very quickly we invent something awesome
and then turn it into war machines
almost immediately
um wait what is jerk the air florist
museum first off it's free and second up
it is like world-renowned like people
come from all over the world to see that
place so it is pretty it is pretty
insane to see like what we as humans can
build it's such that they're killing
machines for Magura
but the car but there are other things
there besides
planes that blow stuff up so that's
definitely something to do I'm sure we
both have two things here some of the
best coffee in the country is a press
coffee house so if you're going to get
coffee you got to stop by there Ryan do
you like do you like Thai food
willing to try anything one okay well
this is the place to try it
it's called tie nine it's down in the
Oregon district it's really close to
press coffee axe actually Josh and I we
joke around a lot like Elrond we're on
the you know lessons now tour slash the
coffee tour slash the the Thai food tour
and so I have eaten
I've eaten Thai food in 49 states in
countless number of cities probably set
on promises in Canada Thai nine has the
best Thai food I have ever had even like
I've had it in the UK Australia Thai
mine is the best Thai food in the world
and you have to get if you're only if
you're going to try one you have to get
massaman curry it is like on its
unbeatable massaman curry I hope you're
writing this down then you're really
you're really going to enjoy this man
what else is there to think of another
favorite restaurant Asian Art Museum
evacs mrs. Deighton visual arts center
and just walk around downtown you can
definitely appreciate it definitely walk
around like university didn't campus to
us really nice thanks for the question
got it
thank you so much for all that you're
doing to add value to everyone's lives
you're welcome what's your name my name
is Heather from Akron Oh welcome Afrin
is in the house tonight
so my question is in response to a
recent podcast we put out on hoarding
and I'm doing my dishes at home I'm
listening to your podcast on hoarding
and the two of you had a conversation
about the field of curation and you want
us to reprise the argument on the stage
we were just as fun as last night in
Columbus we were this will be the second
night in a row we've hashed this out so
I'm not on stage though no wasn't on
stage II was in the Huglin Ohio has a
lot of museum so this is why I'm asking
for all of us museum professionals I
happen to be a curator full time
I'm also a minimalist in my personal
life and through my job I'm able to tell
a lot of incredible stories add a lot of
value to people's lives through
exhibition and I also manage a
collection and of thousands and
thousands and thousands of things so I
understand the value I'm adding to
future generations is huge but I'm
wondering what your advice would be for
unifying your personal values with some
elements of your professional life that
might be in tension with that even
though you're recognized how important
it is I do it so Ryan and I have a
different opinion on this apparently so
I was it was semantics but let's go for
it well yeah let's go for it
so I so first off I was the one who was
Pro museums and saying that wasn't
hoarding and Ryan just to reprise the
argument here Ryan was saying that
museums are hoarding and and I am for
seems by the way hold on and and and
what I will say is I think amateur
collecting is well planned hoarding and
that's why I leave it up to the experts
because I think curators are the people
who can take what would otherwise be a
hoard and curate it into something
meaningful intentional and necessary for
current and future generations
that's pity good no I was arguing over
semantics which is what I do sometimes
um what is synonymous with collection
what do you what do you always say is
synonymous with collection synonymous of
collection is hoard correct yes what is
a museum do curates right
and they've been very nice they've been
nice you just literally said I'm using
your words these are your words they
have a well curated collection so yeah
all I was saying all I was saying is
that when the library Congress they
literally take every tweet and keep it
and they should and they absolutely
should keep him from free sure
generations I was just arguing over
semantics I'm so glad we can hash this
out in front of like 400 people man
um no I I think my pace the answer would
be going on working
uh yeah processing buffering unless
unless unless you are a professional
curator you're probably just hoarding
oh hello Aaron Aaron
welcome um my question is regarding some
in my mid-20s and at the time where I'm
saving to buy all the stuff you know um
so what stuff you save it saving to buy
we're ready to buy our first house
mostly we're I guess thinking about
house okay cool um I guess my question
is what are you guys now saving for or
doing with your money because if you're
not buying stuff you travel or like josh
has a secret place in Malibu collection
of Lamborghini I'm a beach house that's
just full of things now actually we're
investing in the storage unit business
[Laughter]
that would be one hell of a twist so I
think it's an important question and and
you know I think that the question about
our resources important is important
because Ryan and I certainly aren't
allergic to money right I grew up poor
and then in my 20s became relatively
wealthy and then walked away from that
and I learned both sides of like true
poverty like electric being cut off
poverty to at least all sensible wealth
right I had all the trinkets of success
the Lexus is Lex I if you have if you
have more than one I don't know the
plural and I had the big suburban house
and the stuff
and and so I was just sort of wasting
that resource I wasn't very deliberate
with with the money that I was earning I
made good money but spend even better
money and thus had six figures worth of
debt half a million dollars in debt if
you count my mortgage and man I didn't
realize at the time I do it now in the
rearview looking back like the reason we
were unhappy when I was growing up had
less to do with him
out of money that we brought in and had
more to do with the repeated bad
decisions that were being made and the
odd thing is as I started making money
it allowed me to amplify those bad
decisions and and then creditors they
started coming to me and offering me
like credit cards and lines of credit
and you'd be stupid not to right right
and all then I see the sale right it's
50% off and I'm like now I realize that
it's a hundred percent off if you don't
buy it and and so I now no matter what
my resources are I try to find ways to
be delivered with it and so a few things
one is yes I do save and so if you want
to see my personal net worth you can go
to the minimalists comm slash retirement
you can see it down to the penny - a few
market fluctuations there it was updated
relatively recently and on top of that
what Ryan and I do now is we focus a lot
more contribution right so we invest in
the people around us so whether it's
Jessica we were talking about earlier we
bring her on the road with us we pay her
to my mind has changed yeah better yeah
so we we pay chess to do all of our
social media she handles our minimalist
work stuff occasionally she fixes our
hair for us and in the podcast Jean
podcast Jean is back there tightening
the shadows ladies and gentlemen yes we
love you Sean Sean is our podcast
producer he is a tour manager he's our
operations director and he is an
all-around outstanding guy thank you for
what you do Sean we appreciate you man
and so allows us to invest in people
like that
and other people around us as well you
know we have a web development team and
all the stuff there's a lot of people
behind the minimalists but on top of
that and just as important is we find
other ways to contribute to either our
community or the community worldwide so
give you an example the first wave of
this tour we donated the profits from
that to build an orphanage on the
us-mexico border and so Ryan and I
didn't get any
camed at all thank you and it's not 100%
altruistic like makes me feel really
good to be able to do something like
that
but also it inspires other people to do
something similar so last month is
another example and you all heard of the
against malaria foundation yeah there's
some one but hopefully now all of you
have and so last month we we were able
to donate about seventy five hundred
dollars to save a bunch of lives did you
know that that out of everyone who's
ever lived on planet Earth
half of those people have died from
malaria out of everyone who has ever
lived half of them have died from
malaria and it cost about five bucks for
an insecticide treated mosquito net and
so the against malaria foundation
according to give well.org is the most
effective charity in the world they have
the highest rankings of all nonprofits
and so what we did is we reach out to
our audience and said hey for every
review we get on our podcast which gets
our this word out for more people Ryan
and I will personally donate ten bucks
to the against malaria foundation and on
top of that we encourage you to also
Dennett donate on top of that and then
we had a secret person donate another
seventy five hundred dollars on top of
that and double it up and so being able
to save people's lives that way we've
also built some elementary schools and
we've funded high schools we helped the
there was a terrible tragedy last year
in Orlando or the pulse nightclub got
shot up and forty nine people died the
52 people survived wherein were injured
and so we were able to help those people
who were injured from that we didn't
event down there and donated all the
profits to that and so while I said like
I said Ryan and I aren't allergic to
money there's nothing inherently wrong
with money the question is when we have
access to more of it what are we going
to do with it that's my pity part sounds
good
yeah we've done all that uh it's awesome
like I can uh I'm not like I gotta be
really broad with this because I don't
want to call anybody that I known who
have helped out but like I am also able
to help people out on an individual
basis with with certain things I'll just
say that friends and family that I just
I'm really happy to be able to reach out
now and yes certainly I'm saving for
retirement I mean that's when we see get
that question a lot we don't get it too
much anymore but what a minimal issue
what aren't you worried about retirement
it's like yes like I did eventually like
yeah you're going to have to have
something saved up so in fact I you know
I was able to save more money like that
first year after I left my job I saved
more money that year than I had like the
entire and I only made like twenty four
thousand bucks a year and it's and it's
because I was drowning in debt and I was
like I said in my talk I was spending
money faster than I was earning it oh
and this might be my pet the answer um
my secret to being financially secure is
I always spend less money than what I
make a salad I want to apologize to the
rest of the folks in line I am exactly
two minutes over at this point and I
have a few other things to get to you
will get a hug in line I promise I'm so
sorry that we're never to get to your
questions but if you do call in I
promise we will get to it eventually so
there's someone crying in the back she
gave me the tears I'm so sorry but we
get to move on to the added value
segment of the show usually this is
where Ryan I recommend something that
has added value to our lives recently
but since we're in Cleveland we might as
well do something that's its local Ryan
as anything added value to your life in
Cleveland today have any el8 it Mabel's
barbecue
my god I started eating meat like two
years ago again oh I'm so happy if you
haven't been like oh it's so good
it's the brisket the pork is the what
else we got like the ger the greens I
love me some like good good good cooked
greens and yeah they were they were
awesome and the barbecue sauce to have
on the table and also we had picked ale
we had picked a love pig ears you got to
be brave to try those guys and if you're
vegan they have pickles so we are on the
coffeehouse tour of North America Ryan
and I opened up a coffeehouse last year
in Saint Petersburg Florida and it's
called bandit and we're always like
looking for your new ideas for different
places and allowing other other places
to shape our aesthetics and our palates
and man I was at an outstanding coffee
house today it's called pour and it's
less than a mile from here it's it was
truly outstanding so hopefully I'll be
able to go back again before we head out
tomorrow morning let's move on real
quick to right here right now it's of
Orion and I talked about what's going on
in the lives of the minimalist I've
mentioned it once but we're ending right
now in Cleveland the first leg of the
lessons now tour starting at the end of
August we're headed up to Canada we are
doing six or seven stops in Canada it
will be in New York and Brooklyn and and
Philadelphia we'll be in Phoenix and
Salt Lake City and I'm going to try to
go through all these people you think I
can do it
Phoenix Salt Lake City Denver Tampa
Atlanta Nashville we're ending the tour
in December in Milwaukee and Detroit I
was told that that's where you're
supposed to be in December Detroit
no no I'm yeah we are we've never done a
stop and destroy which is pretty awesome
yeah we're heading a bunch of other
cities as well I'm sure I owe Texas
we're headed we're going to go
international we'll be in Austin and
Dallas and Houston and I think what
there's a few other cities and they were
in there as well go to lessons now comm
final details of that check out the
hashtag lessons now for the photos folks
are going to close tonight and from
other nights also Ryan and I this is
where this is the part of the podcast
where we usually spend a few minutes
talking about all of our sponsors and
advertisers right man Josh I just got
these underwear helps my sweaty butt
Ryan don't you hate going to the post
office you having trouble sleeping at
night
look advertisements suck y'all and so
speaking of making money we we turned
down a whole lot of money because we
refuse to do advertisements on this
podcast because you all are inundated
with about 5,000 advertisements a day
and we don't want to make it 5,000 and 1
or 5,000 and three and and so let's not
add to that but we could use your help
Ryan and I want to do a lot more
meaningful stuff with this podcast we
want to do longer episodes shorter
episodes we want to do some interviews
we want to be able to continue to pay
podcast Sean a full-time living wage
I know his three children appreciate
that and we also want to hire a
full-time filmmaker because we saw how
much the documentary resonate with folks
and we want to be able to create
meaningful video creations and so a
video version of this podcast but we
also want to do video interviews we're
going to do TV shows and web series all
on our own we don't have to be beholden
to anyone else
and so we could really use your help if
you want to contribute to the calls all
you have to do is go to the minimalists
com click on the donate button we set up
something called a patreon page which
allows you to contribute on a per
episode basis you can also cap that so
if Ryan and I decide to put out 100
episodes in one month or something you
we're not going to charge you hundreds
of dollars for our podcast but
you can help us out because we don't
want to clutter the podcast with any
advertisements and so what we're really
looking to do is get to 5,000 patrons we
have 3 million downloads a month plus
and so a very small percentage if those
of you who can afford it can help out we
can really do something meaningful and
we can change a lot by sharing this
message in many ways to more people so
head on over to the minimalists comm and
click on the donate button if you find
value in this we'd really really
appreciate that and before we head out
we'll be out there in about 20 minutes
with books which are you can buy one if
you want if you don't have if you didn't
bring your wallet or you can't afford a
book Ryan and I will be happy to to buy
one for you it's on us and it's if you
do get a book please minimize it
afterward find a library or a friend
family member and enemy whomever you're
welcome to pass it on after that we'll
also be out there with hugs and taking
pictures and all that fun stuff before
we before we leave I want to say thanks
to the House of Blues for having us here
tonight yeah
this this is Josh and eyes like first
legit tour where we show up and there's
like a staff of people who just make
everything happen and it's such an
awesome staff here like we just it's so
nice to show up and just not have to
worry about every single thing ourselves
yeah and so you all gave up an important
resource tonight you paid to be here and
that allows us to pay the staff and the
venue and and it's pretty expensive to
to have a place like that we're grateful
but it's even more expensive because you
spent your - more precious resources
it's a different expense it's your time
and your attention and those are
non-renewable resources and we're really
grateful that you chose to spend that
time with us and so there's one last
person I want to thank before we head
out of here and that person is you if
you leave here with one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works Thank
You Cleveland so hi my name is Terra
I'm calling from Eugene Oregon and my
comment it's a tip for people playing
the minimal of minimalism game when
you're not dealing with things which are
fairly straightforward and to get rid of
but papers or things or to do it and I
found that what they take up mostly is
time so the way I've been handling it is
instead of doing one piece of paper I do
one minute and then build up to 30
minutes and that's a good way of
limiting the time that you're spending
on those piles of papers but eventually
getting through them so instead of one
paper he stay then two and three - one
minute two minutes I'm working your way
up to
29 and 30 31 minutes all right bye
hi this is Katie from Glen Ellyn
Illinois on how not to get too seduced
by new shiny things and then feeling
guilty about buying them I also have a
problem with getting really excited
about new shiny thing and what has
really helped me reduce those impulse
purchases is when I see something new
and shiny maybe it reaction is yes I
want to buy this instead of throwing it
in the basket or shopping cart I will
physically carry it in my hands while I
continue to walk around the store and
shop this is two things number one it
helps me understand the physical bulk
this thing will take up in my life if I
buy it it makes the idea of the true
cost of living with this item much more
tangible and number two by the time I'm
done walking around for the initial high
of wanting and then holding this new
shiny thing 10 worn off carrying the
item around and for essentially tricks
my impulse motivated brain into thinking
that I have purchased this item and the
impulse has been satisfied without
having to actually buy it I have
appreciated the object as much as
possible and then I moved on remember
you can appreciate something without
having to buy it or own it and that has
helped me immensely with impulse
purchases thanks bye
my name is Tristan Ryan calling from
Melbourne Florida Ryan's comment about
wanting to talk about the environment
without being negative resonated with me
I have increasing concerns myself and
I'm changing and adapting and part of me
keeps this to myself so I don't come
across as the self-righteous do better
on one hand and then on the other hand I
don't like to bring it up because I
don't want to be criticized when my
efforts are less than perfect one of the
easiest and best things that my husband
and I have done to affect change in our
children is to take them to the dump I
know that that's really funny but when
they see and smell and experience the
trash it makes such a huge impact on
them
the questions to follow have been really
good and it creates an ongoing
conversation but weeds to a lot of
different rabbit trails but the virtues
of just eating an apple
rather than having apple sauce packets
not leaves the conversation also into
appreciating the mangoes that the
neighbor gave you because they didn't
even have to come in a truck from across
the United States so we've been able to
create these conversations and it's been
a really good thing for our family to
help align with our simple lifestyle
it's the perfect opportunity to explain
why we choose the best things that our
money can buy the fewest amount that we
can or the smallest amount that we can
and why we keep those things and we
don't just constantly change and dispose
of things that have value and I'm
talking about things like couches and
mattresses we try and be intentional
with our purchases it's hard to think of
things being easily disposed of when you
witness the stacks of mattresses and
couches and the birds pecking at them
and you we see that firsthand and it
makes such a huge impact on me as an
adult but specifically the kids
thanks guys for what you do love it hey
everybody its Joshua films Millburn and
I am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalist I was just looking up the
dates for the second leg of the lessons
now torso so Ryan and I we are in the
middle of this crazy 40 city tour we're
doing a live talk about minimalism in
depth talk about minimalism we're also
recording a live version of the
minimalist podcast we're answering a
bunch of your questions in person and oh
yeah we dish out a bunch of free hugs
after we're optional hugs yes yeah we do
hand hugs too if they if that's your
thing whatever you like we were looking
forward to seeing you on the road you
can head on over to les is now calm but
here's the cities that we're coming to
for the second leg of this 40 City tour
we're gonna be in Canada again oh man I
can't wait I love Canada
we're going to be at Toronto Ottawa
Montreal Vancouver Calgary Edmonton but
then we're headed to the east coast of
the United States we're going to be in
Philadelphia we'll be in Manhattan and
Brooklyn two stops in New York one oh
you've made it
well we've never had a stop in Brooklyn
so that's pretty cool yeah and then
we'll be in Salt Lake City Denver and
Phoenix heading over to the mountains
and then we're touring internationally
we'll be in Texas where we're going to
be in Austin and Dallas and Houston and
then nashville washington DC atlanta and
tampa we're finishing off with the south
almost but then there's no better place
to spend december than in detroit and
Milwaukee wait who told you that our
booking agent Oh perfect yeah so we're
going to be a Detroit in Milwaukee
that's we're going to finish the les is
now tour this year Helen over to Les is
now calm you can get your tickets you
can find the dates the theaters and you
can see us soon
[Music]
every little singing you think that's me
every little thing you think that to me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bear that you were fine
without it
[Music]
every little thing that you got ahead
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you gotta grab oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you so
tear your eyes
[Music]